[Music]
on this monday night the rcmp lifts the
lid on its once secret spyware
the powerful program capable of
eavesdropping on your phone calls now
you're saying it's 49 individuals that
we're actually spied on what else it can
do when it's supposed to be used and the
concerns about your privacy
volatile conditions
the wildfire is igniting newfoundland
labrador's state of emergency pleading
its case why one airline wants its top
execs to be baggage handlers and a
beloved songstress forever silenced
[Music]
the life and death of olivia newton-john
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
just hours ago at a routine hearing in
ottawa canadians began to learn more
about a bombshell revelation that took
even the country's privacy commissioner
by surprise
a previously secret system that allows
law enforcement to listen in and even
take control of anyone's smartphone and
we are learning the rcmp may have used
it much more than they previously
admitted our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson joins us now with
the details
mercedes this sounds like something out
of a spy movie
well jafar it's pretty incredible
technology in terms of what it can do it
can intercept phone calls and text
messages coming to or from your phone
but beyond that it can also access media
files and what i found really
interesting you can turn on this right
here your camera and your microphone so
it can see and hear people around you
and obviously that's raising some
privacy concerns for not only the people
who might be under investigation but
people who could simply be within
earshot or eye shot of these devices
documents obtained by global news reveal
that the rcmp are using this spyware far
more than what the mounties had
previously revealed to parliament in a
letter to the ethics committee rcmp
commissioner brenda lucky says on device
intercept tools which is what they call
them have been used in 32 investigations
since 2017. in that time the rcmp
received judicial authorization that
they could look at up to 144 of these
devices but they only actually monitored
49 according to lucky the use of this
technology appears to be on the rise too
with nine of the 32 investigations
taking place this year alone and it's
not clear far why there's been such a
substantial jump in their use in the
most recent year
i mean another question when can
authorities use use this technology what
are the rules
well great question especially since
we're just learning about it with these
kinds of capabilities there are
obviously concerns about when and how
the technology is used as well as who is
being targeted we don't know a lot about
the bar for the rcmp to gather
intelligence this way but we do know
some of the types of investigations that
it's been used in including
counterterrorism cases drug cases
murders and in one police breach of
trust case we also know that the police
have to get judicial authorization to do
this so it's not just a free-for-all but
the privacy commissioner says well there
can absolutely be a bar for this kind of
thing in the public interest the failure
of the rcmp to disclose that this
existed or how it was being used as well
as answering any questions around
precautions that are being taken raise
major concerns he brought that up today
and the minister of public safety tried
to address it listen to this
these tools may well be needed
but
do they have an impact from a privacy
standpoint that is greater than what is
warranted given given the purpose so
this is an important question this is a
this is the central question that there
are rigorous protections which are put
into place prior to the authorization of
this particular technique including
applications which must go to a superior
court judge on the strength of a
designated agent who puts forward a
thorough uh recitation of the facts on
which
the authorization is being sought
the rcmp say only about one in ten
applications to use this spyware
actually gets approved but there are
major concerns about the kind of
precedent that this is set in canada in
canada pharah as well as globally just
given the incredible capabilities that
this technology has and not a lot of
answers on how it's being used all right
i know you'll continue to follow it
mercedes stevenson in ottawa for us
thanks mercedes
some sad news to tell you about now
former liberal cabinet minister bill
graham has died
bill graham was foreign affairs minister
when canada decided against joining the
u.s invasion of iraq in 2003 under prime
minister jacques
and was minister of national defense
under prime minister paul martin and
also served as opposition leader and
interim leader of the liberal party in a
tweet minister of transport omar
al-gabra said bill graham was a friend
and mentor and a giant in canadian and
international politics who wore his love
for canada on his sleeve
bill graham was 83.
the summer heat has created frightening
wildfire situations in several parts of
the country on both the east and west
coast families have been forced out of
their homes to get out of the path of
out of control wildfires the
newfoundland and labrador government has
now declared a state of emergency as
hundreds of homes have been placed under
evacuation alerts as abigail beeman
reports the wildfire situation in the
province is now being described as the
worst in more than 50 years
as out of control fires continue to burn
in central newfoundland people there are
being forced into making tough choices
having to wait in a lineup for hours
and then just be turned around it's
quite frustrating julie murphy is
stranded with family trying to get home
to grand falls windsor but fire and
smoke has closed the highway and with
store shelves depleted she was almost
out of formula for her two-month-old
until a facebook post netted kindness
from across canada i never ever thought
that so many people will come together
and help me in this situation with her
being so small and having not much
formula at all meanwhile in grand falls
windsor the first optional evacuation
buses are taking people who want to
leave out of town in light that it could
happen so quickly that if we got into a
mass exodus we wouldn't want our
vulnerable population people with
mobility issues and and those sorts of
things to be
caught up in that
rush hospitals and senior facilities in
the area are also transferring people
including 95 year old bernice lane i
don't know if she's going to be over
there two days two weeks
and
you can't prepare for
i can't take enough with me for six
months or i can't go for six months help
has poured into the province including
half a dozen members of the canadian
armed forces and the salvation army has
already served up 700 meals to people in
the community and on the front lines
people are feeling a high level of
anxiety and and stress over this
particular situation and how it's
impacting them how it's impacting their
families some people have been
disconnected from families now for a
number of days the good news the winds
and heat haven't been as high as
expected fire itself hadn't progressed
very far at all in the last 24 hours but
everyone is praying for rain and knows
things can get worse without warning
abigail beeman global news
in the british columbia interior some
reprieve wildfire fighting crews say the
weather is working in their favor and
fighting the karemius creek fire more
than 400 firefighters are now on scene
over the weekend crews deliberately
started small fires on both the southern
and northern flanks of the 6 000 hectare
fire to remove fuel and create
containment lines those efforts are
expected to continue over the coming
days leading to more smoky skies over
the region while the existing evacuation
orders and alerts are expected to stay
in place
these fires reflect what's been a
scorching weekend for a large swath of
our country and temperatures aren't
easing up just yet residents in parts of
bc alberta and much of ontario still
face heat warnings with no sign of
relief in some areas until later this
week and as jamie morocco explains
wildfires are not the sweltering
conditions can pose serious health risks
to canadians
don't let the clouds fool you it's still
hot and muggy in toronto following a
weekend humidex in the 40s that's
sticking around
load up on the water sunscreen wear your
hats good advice with the dog days of
summer expected to stretch into fall
i'm especially concerned about the
western half of canada they got off to a
slow start in bc very wet cool spring
things have changed around and now of
course the forest fire risk is going up
and we've got a lot of warmth that i see
setting up being unprepared for the
scorching temperatures can quickly
become a medical emergency
first
the weather changed it may be a show set
in frigid temperatures but heat exposure
is the reason production was suspended
on netflix's snow piercer after several
crew members fell ill during a heat wave
in july leading work safe b.c to
investigate
heat has become the deadliest form of
extreme weather in our country killing
more canadians than fires or floods last
summer it was responsible for more than
3 500 deaths across alberta and b.c over
a two-week period and while we can't
stop the mercury from rising experts say
people and communities can better
prepare planting more trees for shade
painting roofs white to reflect pounding
sun and making air conditioning a
national priority we expect people to
have heat in the winter time we need to
think about air conditioning
also is a right in the summer time
because when these extreme heat events
happen we need to make sure that they
don't turn lethal we have a house that
doesn't have open windows so you can't
vent it out in vancouver some locals
rely on the beach breeze instead even
when we get the heat waves
it's two three weeks long it's not a
long time but they are becoming annual
occurrences and a reality most canadians
will have to adapt to jamie morocco
global news
toronto in europe the wildfire season is
still only half over but the summer has
already become the second worst ever
recorded in terms of area burned
french crews have been mobilized to
fight more than a dozen significant
fires around the country that are
threatening homes villages and farmland
more than 100 other smaller fires are
also being fought in the italian
province of savona more than 120
residents of one village were forced
from their homes it's believed multiple
structures have been destroyed large
parts of italy spain and france remain
under extreme fire danger warnings
the u.s is facing all kinds of extreme
weather from devastating flash flooding
to explosive wildfires fueled by severe
drought but there are some hopeful signs
that the country is getting serious
about tackling global warming after the
senate passed legislation that it will
pour billions of dollars into clean
energy as jackson prescott reports the
bill salvages a big part of president
joe biden's domestic agenda ahead of the
upcoming midterms
in kentucky president joe biden toured
the damage from the latest climate
catastrophe
while back in washington signs of
optimism the u.s may still avoid the
worst impacts of a warming planet after
democrats passed the most substantial
legislation on climate in u.s history
we've changed the world
in a way that you rarely get an
opportunity to do that and the bill as
amended is passed
it took a marathon 22 hours of voting to
pass the so-called inflation reduction
act fulfilling biden's signature promise
to spend hundreds of billions of dollars
on climate and health care paid for by
tax increases on the largest
corporations every single republican
objected the bill's title shows you what
it is it's an inflation increase act the
bill includes 369 billion dollars in
incentives for clean energy programs
including tax credits encouraging
american consumers to buy electric
vehicles including evs built in canada
there's just a variety of investments
here that make a lot of sense if what
you're trying to do is spark clean
energy innovation and also create the
sort of government funding that will
help attract private funding it all puts
the u.s on a better course to meeting
its emission reduction promises
the spending could help cut u.s
emissions to about 40 percent below 2005
levels by the end of the decade though
still shy of commitments under the paris
accord what this legislation shows is
that there's a backbone to those
commitments that helps us go into the
international arena and say okay now
let's talk about what other countries
can contribute to this effort to reduce
global emissions for biden it's not just
a moral victory it's a political one
less than 100 days before midterm
elections and with his own approval
numbers faltering the president has
cemented a consequential part of his
legacy that could shape american life
for decades to come
jackson prosco global news washington
a deadly and dangerous inferno in cuba
coming up fighting the flames at the
country's largest oil storage facility
following three days of deadly violence
the fragile ceasefire between israel and
gaza now appears to be holding the
agreement went into force on sunday
after at least 44 people in gaza
including 15 children were killed in 56
hours of violence
in response palestinian militants fired
more than 1 000 rockets at israel but
there were no serious casualties on the
israeli side thanks largely due to the
country's iron dome defense system with
the truce holding israel has reopened
border crossings allowing fuel trucks to
supply gaza's only power plant and
increase the availability of electricity
which was down to around eight hours a
day
ukraine and russia blaming each other
for the repeated shelling of europe's
largest nuclear power plant the zaparica
nuclear facility was captured by russian
forces back in march but it is still
being operated by ukrainian technicians
over the past few days the complex has
been hit several times by artillery and
rocket fire with both sides blaming each
other and warning of a potential nuclear
disaster if critical components are
damaged the u.n nuclear watchdog is
calling for utmost restraint the plant's
located just outside a russian-held city
with a population of more than 50 000
people
after a dangerous and difficult journey
through the black sea the first ship
carrying ukrainian grain has now docked
at a turkish port the polar net left
odessa friday carrying 12 000 tons of
corn after being trapped in port for
months during the voyage the ship had to
navigate a narrow passage through
minefields and undergo a series of
international inspections also today two
more grain ships left ukrainian ports
bringing the number of vessels sailing
under the u.n brokered safe passage deal
to 10.
fire crews are struggling to contain a
huge blaze at cuba's largest oil storage
facility
overnight a second oil tank at the
matanzas super tank port caught fire and
exploded fire has been spreading through
the facility since friday when it was
hit by lightning at least one
firefighter has been killed and 16
people are missing the fire is expected
to worsen cuba's ongoing fuel crisis the
port's located about 100 kilometers east
of havana
sharing the load ahead why one of the
world's biggest airlines is asking its
bosses to help with the bags
air travel this summer has been plagued
by lengthy delays just about everywhere
and canadian airlines and airports are
not immune to the pandemic fueled
staffing issues making for long lines
and lost luggage today it was revealed
the house of commons transport committee
is going to investigate airport delays
and flight cancellations but in
australia qantas is trying to solve the
problem by asking top executives to do
some heavy lifting
literally here's redmond shannon
air travel has arguably never been so
unglamorous summer flyers faced with
mountains of lost bags long lines delays
and cancellations canadian airlines and
airports creaking under post-pandemic
staffing pressures the plan that we have
been working in concerted effort the
intensity of that with our with our
partners
is yielding results but not quickly
enough according to flightaware.com on
sunday both montreal and toronto were
among the worst eight airports in the
world for delayed departures and
canadian operators dominated the top ten
list of airlines with the worst delay
rate
australian carrier qantas is getting
creative the airline reportedly asking
executives to roll up their sleeves and
get down to the ramp to volunteer some
of their work week in baggage handling
the union representing baggage workers
in australia is calling the move
dangerous and bizarre given it was the
same managers who laid off those workers
during the pandemic he who dances will
pay the paper isn't that what they say
so if we need a bunch of bags moved by
highly qualified trained personnel then
we're going to have to highly qualify
and train some personnel aviation expert
jock williams says the training for some
of those roles could be done quickly but
paying executive salaries for the work
is bad value arguably the employee can
take the position that look this isn't
what i was hired to do appointment
lawyer meniza sheikh says no workers
could be forced into doing these tasks
but she understands why some executives
may want to get their hands dirty it
sends very positive messaging to
employees that ultimately everyone wants
to see the business grow and it's not
going to be just on the backs and
shoulders of the more mid-level
employees the union representing baggage
handlers for air canada and westjet says
those airlines have not tried this
strategy redman shannon global news
london
next remembering olivia newton-john the
hit singer and greece star who stole the
world's hearts
a pop culture icon has died olivia
newton-john or sandy as generations
would come to know her found enduring
fame starring in greece but her career
in stardom began long before that as a
pop princess in the 60s turned country
star and grammy award winner
after her breast cancer diagnosis 30
years ago she added cancer advocate to
the list and was more recently named
dame olivia honored for her music and
charity work eric sorenson looks back at
her life and legacy
[Music]
her soft voice and wholesome looks
almost overnight brought olivia
newton-john stardom in the 1970s a
soothing sound from a seemingly innocent
source in an era buffeted by hard rock
and disco music
[Applause]
newton john was born in england and
emigrated to australia as a child she
had early success in music competitions
and soon the number one songs came one
after another
[Music]
she shot the global fame when she was
cast in the film musical grease
playing sandy opposite john travolta she
transforms from the girl next door to
something else altogether
in fact her musical style soon became
less innocent much more daring too with
physical one of the biggest hits in the
entire pop era
a major setback came in 1992 the year
she turned 44 diagnosed with breast
cancer i'm not afraid of anything right
now newton john had been a longtime
advocate for the environment and animal
rights but now poured much of her energy
into her own cancer foundation i've
chosen that path to be grateful and to
feel good about things because the other
side's not so good she spoke to et
canada about her emphasis on plant-based
treatments for cancer i've lost way too
many friends to cancer and you know i'm
on that journey myself so i'm really
powerfully driven to find kinder answers
for treatments for cancer she remained
active and popular fans still enjoyed
her music and always remembered sandy
from greece 40 years later who would
have thunk it we feel very grateful that
this is still a part of everyone's
they love it her cancer returned for the
third time five years ago
a singer best remembered as a young
fresh-faced star in the making suddenly
gone at age 73.
she just exuded positivity that's global
national for this monday night i'm farah
nasser on behalf of our whole team i
want to thank you for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
canada is the rotary mattamy greenway in
calgary until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other have a good
night
[Music]
you